[Music]
hi everyone I'm here and I'm a software
engineer on Google Play hi everyone I'm
Anthony also a software engineer on
Google Play and I'm Evo a partner dual
provoker that Google some of you may
just be coming from the previous session
at the entry theater which gave an
overview of Google Play didn't dynamic
delivery and its new publishing format
called the Android app bundle and how
this will make apps smaller in this
session we will do a technical deep dive
on this new publishing format we will
cover what it contains how to build it
how to publish it but also the different
ways you can test it
we'll also cover how Google Play
generates and serves the apks to
end-users so let's start with the format
of the Android app on both the Android
app bundle is receive archive it
contains the files you're already
familiar with in ATK's such as text
files android resources assets native
libraries it's important to realize that
the app bundle and the apk are two
distinct formats with two different
purposes the app bundle is a purely is
purely a publishing format so it cannot
be directly installed on a device it
also contains some metadata files that
don't end up in the final AP case it
just helped the tools built the apk is
the right way
finally the format of the app bundle is
stricter than apk we want to ensure that
the tools can fully understand the files
in the bundle so that they can generate
valid apks now let's open up one app
bundle and looks what's inside so if you
open up an app bundle this is what you
should expect so this should look
familiar to a lot of people instead of
reinventing the wheel we decided to
reuse some of the structure of ATK's and
only modify what we needed to better
describe the files so we'll literally
goes through them
to start with the app bundle has support
for having multiple modules as you may
have heard before and will tell you more
about Banjul about modules shortly for
now just know that the top-level
directories in the app bundle are the
names of the modules there is always a
module named base in the module in the
bundle and that's the one we're looking
at here the Android manifest is still
present in your project it's a real XML
file in the AP case you may know it's a
binary format in the app bundle it's
compiled into protocol buffer formats
which allows us to transform it more
easily as opposed to apk the Dex files
are under directory named text the
Android resources the assets and the
native libraries on the other hand
follow the same directory structure as
in an apk the only difference are the
XML resources which are also compiled
into a protocol buffer format instead of
the binary format the file resources
that TB is the resource table is the
equivalent of the file resources that a
RSC that you may have seen in your apks
it describes the resources present in
your app and the targeting the dot TB
extension bits in in a protocol buffer
format which again makes it easier for
tools to transform it before it's
converted into its binary form in the
apk the assets the TB and native dot TB
files are the equivalent of the resource
table for assets and native libraries so
they only exist if you have assets or
native libraries and they also describe
the targeting of the files in their
respective directories as I've mentioned
before the resource table the asset
table and the native libraries table
describe the targeting of the files of
your app so they let me explain what I
mean by that file targeting is the
description of what type of device or
user a given file is targeted for it's a
central concept in Google Play dynamic
delivery since understanding the
targeting of files means we can serve to
a given user only the files they need
and this is what allows us to make
smaller the app bundle reuses the
targeting that exists in AP case you
already familiar with this so I'll just
go I'll run through quickly for
resources you specify for example hdpi
in the directory name of your resource
to target hdpi devices or you add FR to
target french users for native libraries
it's the same you add the architecture
to the directory again nothing new here
the app on door works the same way now
we realize that for some of you assets
represent a big part of your app so the
app bundle also supports assets
targeting we are starting with language
targeting and we will soon be adding
texture compression formats and graphics
API versions so we can serve only the
relevant assets to the users and reduce
further the size of your apps and games
this is how you would create a targeted
assets directory while making use of the
hash sign to identify an asset directory
that has targeting then come the key
which defines which dimensions we are
targeting for example language for the
language
TCF for texture compression formats etc
and then comes the value associated with
the key but let's see some examples
here's an example of a directory
containing assets or users speaking
French this is another example of an
asset directory targeted based on the
texture compression format here
targeting devices that support the
format et Cie one
now that you know more about the ethanol
formats I'll hand it over to Anthony who
will tell you how we use this to serve
smaller apps to users thanks Pierre hi
everyone so Pierre is just explained to
you how we're changing the format of
what you publish to the Play Store and
now I'm going to explain to you how
we're changing the format of what we
serve to users and how we use this to
deliver only what is needed for each
user now we start with split apks so in
Android lollipop we added a feature to
the Android platform called split apks
split apks allow multiple apks to be
installed on a device and behave as if
they were part of a single app these
split apks can be installed in different
combinations on different devices and
they can be installed in one go up front
or piece-by-piece
now a split apk has the same format as a
normal apk they can contain Java code
index files native code resources and
assets directories and once the date
BK's are installed these can all be as
accessed as if they were in a single apk
and furthermore each split APK shares
the same package name and version code
with all the other ones that are
installed on a device and there must all
be signed with the same kick so now
let's take a look at how we can take the
Android app bundle and generate split
apks that we then serve to devices so we
start by looking in the account bundle
and finding everything that is common to
all the devices and putting those in a
base a became so this would include the
Android manifest file and the Dex files
for instance then we generate a
difference with apk for each screen
density each split will contain all the
drawables that would have been selected
by the android framework on a device
with that density we can also generate a
different split apk for each native
architecture containing native libraries
of that architecture and we can generate
a different split for each language
supported by your app putting each
languages strings in a
different apk now together we call these
splits configuration space or config
space now when we go to serve an app to
a device we only need to serve a subset
of these splits instead of serving
everything to every device so say I have
a Samsung Galaxy j5 we will install the
base apk as well as the xhdpi identity
split the ARM architecture split and the
English language stick because I only
speak English but it can get a bit
trickier than that Pierre speaks both
French and English and he specifies both
of those languages in his device
settings so for his device of pixel to
excel in addition to the right density
and architecture splits we will serve
both the French and the English language
bit to his device
now suppose Pierre then moves to Brazil
and learns Portuguese he might then add
Portuguese as a language on his device
now when he does this the Play Store
recognizes this and will attempt to
download the Portuguese language split
for all apps that use splits on the
device and if the device is not online
at the time then we will download those
language spits at the next opportunity
and so that's how config slips work but
as I mentioned at the start splits are
only supported on lollipop and above
this covers about 85% of users at the
moment but most of you still target pre
L devices which is great and for these
devices the app bundle still allows us
to achieve some of the size savings by
generating standalone apks containing
specific densities and architectures so
instead of generating splits as we would
do for L plus we would generate this
matrix of stand-alone apks we briefly
consider extending this to language
splits as well but we did some of the
sums and it got a little bit out of hand
so for now for pre L devices we asked to
include all the languages in each of the
standalone apks now when we go to serve
the app we choose the best single apk
for a device so if we have my first
Android device the Galaxy Nexus
we would serve the hdpi arm stand-alone
apk you might recognize this because
this is similar to what you may have
done in the past with multi apk but
let's put this all together the picture
looks like this and you actually don't
need to worry about the details about
how all these bit apks are generated or
standalone apks are generated all you
have to do is upload a single app bundle
and then play generates the right splits
and to select the right ones to serve
for each device and the dimensions we've
discussed so far are only the beginning
Pierre discussed how the app bundle lets
you target assets by graphics API and we
will soon generate config splits based
on that we'll also start generating
config splits that take advantage of new
platform features and we'll start with
supporting uncompressed native libraries
on m+ devices now I'll ask Evo to come
up to take a look at how much we can
reduce app size by using this app
Thunder Thank You Anthony
now that we know how play serves with
apks to your devices we're going to talk
about the size savings with upon us we
found out that on average apps published
with F bundles are 20% smaller and that
is release for 20% savings every time
your application is downloaded or
upgraded now let's look at how we reach
to this number we analyzed all the
applications in Play Store with more
than 1 million downloads and we found
out that for Strings we can save over
95% of their size by using the language
splits for images this is 45% and for
native libraries we can say 20% of their
sizes this means if every app virtual
mode to add bundles we would save
approximately 10 terabytes of data per
day from app downloads and updates that
is 10 million gigabytes or 300 million
music videos on YouTube and on top of
that users could see an extra 300
megabytes of disk space for more photos
more apps or more music on their devices
so now let's look at actual size savings
that are some of our early access
program mem partners so we're going to
start with Twitter Twitter were already
publishing with multi apks before with
architectures splits however their
application is translated into a lot of
languages and it supports multiple
screen densities they still get lots of
savings with publishing with app bundles
which is 20% decrease in the size plus
they don't have to serve with multi apk
anymore the next one is text plus which
wasn't using multi apks before but add
bundles they achieved 26% size savings
across all dimensions with app bundles
Jomo's app is half of his original size
and this is because they have a large
need to library and they supported
multiple architectures in a single apk
now let's look at how we can build an
app bundle and he can start saving now
the latest Android studio 3.2 canary has
full support for building Android app
bundles now we're going to see a new
option to build a bundle in the build
menu there anything is signed app bundle
is easy as well we're gonna just select
your app bundle @ab module for that
flavor and build type and Android studio
is going to create an app bundle for you
sign which is ready for publishing for
those who prefer command-line or wish to
integrate with automated build systems
the new Android and Gradle android
plug-in provides a new set of tests to
build Android app bundles if you
remember this is what you use the
assemble tasks on the command
to create the apk now for app bundles
you're going to switch to the bundle
comment similar to the assemble tasks
bundle tests also allow you to build a
specific flavor of your application once
the build the the bundle task finishes
is going to create an app bundle in the
output folder with the flavor and the
build type chosen the build type build
artifact is called bundled IAB bundle
tests are compatible with the signing
config signore built up Gradle files and
with a single Gradle task you can
produce a bundles that are signed and
ready for publishing and also with app
bundles Play will automatically select
your application into architectures
screen density and language splits by
default you don't need to do any
configurations however we still want our
developers to have full control over
their splits so if for any reason you
would like to disable splitting by any
dimension you can do so by using the
newly introduced bundle block here now
pierre is going to talk about how to
publish your app bundle in the Play
console Thank You beau alright so you
have built an app bundle
now let's look at how you can publish it
on Google Play console first you must
enroll in app signing by Google Play for
those who remember we launched this
program at Google i/o last year when
enrolling you securely transfer you
release key to Google Play play then
uses this release key to sign the
generated apks on your behalf
before serving them to users but notes
that if you keep uploading apks on your
production tap track while you test the
app bundle in the test track play will
not resign the uploaded apks and we did
this so you can feel confident trying
the app bundle and small audience first
without affecting your current
production users
once you're enrolled we can manage
releases just like you did for ATK's
create a new release drop the app
bundles in the same location where you
currently drop apks and wait for the air
plot once you upload once uploaded you
can review your release and release out
that's it and I can't stress this enough
no more multi-apk is to deal with play
console has created in the background
all the apks for the supported devices
for you now you have uploaded your app
bundle and play has done all the heavy
lifting for you great but wouldn't it be
nice to be able to have an overview of
what play has generated well we have
built a new tool in play console called
bundle Explorer bundle Explorer lets you
navigate your uploaded bundles let's
have a look on the first screen you can
see at the top right corner the size
savings you gain by publishing a bundle
here we saved over a quarter of your app
of course this is different by device so
we calculated this using a popular
device configuration you will also find
below the list of device configurations
and the total size of the apk served to
those devices can even click on View
Devices and see which devices are in
each pocket you can even search for any
supported device by name to download the
set of generated apks that is served to
that specific device this will be super
helpful when you get you know that bug
report and that specific device and you
want to get exactly what the user has
gotten and what the ATK's were served so
you just search for the name click
download and you'll get the set of ATK's
that play has served of course we
haven't forgotten all of you who use our
publishing API uploading app bundles is
also available using our API today you
will find all the documentation at
developers.google.com slash Android -
publisher I'm now handed over to Anthony
thanks for yeah so we've now learned how
to build and publish an Android app
bundle but before we finalize a release
we'd still like to do a round of tests
however we've seen that the app bundle
on its own is not installable so how do
you test it first we note that during
development you can install apk is built
from the app bundle directly from
Android studio so you don't need to do
anything here however for QA teams we
know that they don't always have access
to the source code in Android studio
so let me talk you through the story of
three developers Alice Bob and Claire
and how they choose to test their app
bundle with a QA teams so let's start
with Alice Alice uses the newly released
internal test track from the Play
console the internal track is similar to
alpha and beta tracks that you may
already be familiar with but it differs
in that there is almost no delay between
the upload of the bundle and the bundle
are the update being available on the
testers devices really quick turnarounds
for your QA testing going through the
Play console Alice has the confidence
that what the QA team will receive on
their device is byte for byte equal with
what end-users will get when you push
your release to production and let's see
how Alice sets this up really simple so
Alice creates a list of emails of up to
100 QA testers that are eligible for the
tip internal test track the QA testers
follow the opt-in link and then now
receive the bundles that are uploaded so
they curate lead to the internal test
track that's it but we know that not all
of you have access to the Play console
during your QA cycles so let's hear from
Pierre about Bob's story indeed Bob
doesn't have access to the Play console
he prefers also to test things locally
on his machine before loading anything
but he still wants to test what the
users will get so how does he do that
well to generate apks from the bundle
Play users a new tool called bundle tool
so for Bob to repute to reproduce
locally the builds
we can simply download bundle toll and
write a few simple comments but not all
has a comment called build the apk which
takes an Android app bundle and creates
what we call an apk set archive this apk
set contains a collection of apks ready
to be installed on devices another
comment
called install apks text that apk set
archive extracts the apks and install
them on that device let's see some real
command-line work so here's the comment
written by Bob calling build apks
passing the app bundle and same way he
wants to wear once the APK said to be
created and by passing the flight
connected device burn until we build
apks just for the device currently
connected to his machine and if bubbles
generate a DK say for someone else in
his team but without having the physical
device at hand it can still provide a
file that contains the specifications of
the device in a JSON format and you can
see here an extract of such file which
provides the information about the api's
this device supports supported languages
the screen density and the SDK version
volatile has also a comment to generate
such device spec file so you don't have
to find the device back online or you
don't have to write it yourself you just
run this command and will generate this
file for you also because Bob wants to
install these apks on a device they DK's
need to be signed with a private key so
he passes the pass to the key store all
the apk is contained in the apk set will
then be signed and directly installable
on Bob's device and here's the
invocation of the install apks comment
which extracts the apks from the efika
set and install them directly on the
connected device easy
so that was Bob and his local testing
now ebo will tell you Claire's a story
Claire is working for a medium-sized
company and they set up a continuous
integration tool to build their
application everyday they create him for
the nightly build of the application
installs in multiple devices and test if
the application is working correctly now
Claire wants Claire wants to help to
create him and she uses the bundle tool
again to generate the apk set in the CI
she uses a command that's very similar
to what Bob used earlier but this time
she omits the device bag flag and she
generates an apk set which contains
apks for all possible devices now the QA
team will just grab the apk set from the
CI they're going to connect the device
and run the install the apk is comment
bundle tool now we'll read the device
configuration from the attached device
will extract the AP case that matches
this configuration from the apk set and
then install them onto the device this
is the same selection that played us and
serving AP case for a given given device
one more thing that bundle tool can do
is to generate the universal apk
bypassing the universal flag Bureau's
whole apk is a single apk that contains
the file all the files or that manages
all the devices because of that it can
be installed in any device well it
really doesn't represent what your what
your users will receive when they
install your applications from Playstore
however this is a convenient way to pass
an apk to a user when you don't know
what device they are running one low
tool is also the tool used to build an
Android app bundle and gretel uses it
behind the scenes we're going to work
with the other build chains to change to
integrate build tool so that you can
build an Android app bundle regardless
of any
Chane you may be using and finally we
want to be transparent about how we
generate the apks we deliver to your
users which is why we are open sourcing
bundle tools we can go today to
github.com slash Google slash bundle
tool to download an executable or build
it from the source now Pierre is going
to talk about another way to make your
applications even smaller XE both with
Google Play dynamic delivery we're also
introducing a new way to break up your
app into separate features and then ever
only those that are needed for each user
suppose you have a recipe app and you
want to keep the initial download small
you observe that while all your users
like to browse or recipes only a small
fraction choose to actually add a new
recipe and you notice that this
functionality Texas takes up significant
space in your app what you can do is
break that feature out into its own
module and serve it only when needed we
can see how it looks for user here let's
open the app so when the user wants to
add a recipe clicks a little plus at the
bottom and you can see that in the
background the module is downloaded and
installed and just after a few seconds
the module is ready to be used so which
parts of your app should you break out
as separate features if only a small
fraction of your users use that feature
that could be a good candidate
especially if that feature takes up
significant space in your app finally
consider if your users can wait a few
seconds before using the feature
once you've decided which feature to
create this is how it should look like
in the app bundle in addition to the
base directory they are now also
separate directories for each of the
modules of the app the format of these
directories is exactly the same as the
format of the base that I mean that I
covered earlier and this is the AP case
that play would generate from it for
each module we will produce a set of
splits consisting of a feature split and
config splits for that module Anthony
mentioned earlier that speed apks were
only introduced with Android lollipop to
support free L devices we can mark
modules to be fused and Bonato will
generate a single ADK with a specified
module merged together now that we have
covered how dynamic features work let me
hand it over to e Bo I will show you how
to create them thanks Pierre
to create a dynamic module all you need
to do is download Android studio 3.2
canary and use the dynamic feature
wizard included click on the new new
module in file menu choose a dynamic
module also typing in your modules name
Android studio is going to create a new
dynamic module for you we can also do
the same thing manually by editing the
manifest and built up Gradle files
you're going to start with the manifest
of your new module the first step is to
declare this module is a new split apk
of your of your app to do so you're
going to add the split attribute in the
manifest tag and give a name which is VR
underscore we are underscore viewer in
this example the next step is to add a
module tag which is which is going to
declare a module and give your gonna
give a title to the module this tag is
used by Plextor to identify the modules
of your application next you declare
this module is an on-demand module by
the on-demand attribute this means that
this module is only going to be
delivered to the users device when the
app requests is from the Play Store
instead of delivering it an install time
of course we now know that on-demand
modules are only supported on helpless
devices so if you choose to also provide
this module in pre all devices you're
going to add the fusing tag to instruct
place for place or to include this
module alongside the base module at the
install time when delivering to PL
devices or in the Universal apk now
let's look at the build up Gradle files
we're going to start with the dynamic
module the first thing is that we are
now using a new plugin called Condit
Android Android - feature the second
thing is we add the base module a Zen
dependency to this to this module so
that we can access the functionality
included in the base module the only
change required in the build up Gradle
file of the base module is to add a
dynamic features list and put all the
dynamic module names into this list this
is to instruct Gradle to make the
resources stored in the base module
available to those dynamic modules now
Anthony is going to show you how you can
use those modules with the new play core
library thanks Ava so let's take a look
at how you go about requesting on-demand
modules to be installed when you want
them to be installed so in order to
interact with the Play Store we are
introducing a split install API as part
of a new library called the play core
library now the play core library is a
Java client library that communicates
with the Play Store via IPC on the
device and in the Play Store
communicates with play servers to
download these on-demand modules when
you request them let's take a look at a
bit of the code the API is structured
using the same task framework that
you're probably familiar with from the
Google Play services API and five
API on Android installation of splits is
coordinated by a class called the split
install manager you construct a request
with all the modules that you wish to
download and then you invoke start
install to trigger the Play Store to
download the splits required for those
requested modules the API also allows
you to listen for updates throughout the
download and install process you can use
this to display progress the download
progress in the install progress to your
users while they are waiting for the on
demand feature to download you saw this
in the video that pierre showed when it
was downloading the address of the
module for large modules you'll need to
obtain user confirmation prior to the
download via this video store api you'll
need to do this whenever the app
requests more than 10 megabytes of
on-demand modules to be downloaded
however there is an alternative option
for installing these modules which if
they aren't required immediately for
immediate use and we call this the
deferred installation api if you request
if you use this simple one line to
request a deferred install of a module
then the module will be downloaded at a
convenient time for the user this is
generally when the user is not using the
device and it's charging and it's on
Wi-Fi and because of this we allow you
to install larger modules by this API
without requiring user confirmation up
to a hundred megabytes and so this is a
really user friendly way to download
large on-demand modules for your app you
can also use the split install API to
manage your on demand modules so you can
see which modules are currently
installed and if your user no longer
needs that module you can request for
the module to be uninstalled freeing up
the precious disk space for your users
and reducing the footprint of your app
on their device
now when you go and install an on-demand
module on n+ devices the app does not
need to be restarted so code is
available immediately upon request on
the install completing and new resources
and assets survey are available once you
refresh your context object however on
Android LNM installing splits requires
the app to restart if you want to
install them properly but to get around
to avoid this we've included a split
compact library which emulates the
installation of a split on L&M until the
app goes into the background and we can
properly install it and so this split
compat library means that your app
doesn't need to restart and all the
things inside this or almost all the
things inside this module are
immediately available to your app you
can set this with compact library up in
a very similar way to how you might be
familiar with setting up the multi decks
library in your apps finally when you
release an update to your hat play will
automatically update both the base
module and any on-demand modules that
are already installed so the versions of
your modules that are on a device are
always in sync they're always at the
same version and partners tell us that
this is something that they really like
about this model all right let's wrap
this all out starting today all
developers can build Android app bundles
in Android studio 3 23.2 canary and
they'll be able to publish these on play
to all users so I encourage all of you
to try this out and see how much smaller
your app could be just by switching to
the Android app bundle now we will be
rolling out motorisation to developers
over the coming months from today you
can start building motorized apps in the
studio canary and you can publish them
to the internal and alpha tracks within
the Play console but we'll be opening up
publishing in production tracks as a
beta over the coming months and if
you're interested you can register your
interest in module ization at the link
provider and with that thank you
everyone for coming if you have any
questions you can grab us afterwards I
don't think we have time right now or
you can grab us over the next couple of
days in the sample
see just behind the stage and then thank
you have a great iron
[Music]